[Music]
good more you know I think I'm just
gonna let Calvin do the intro for today
Calvin how many parts do you think we
want to do today and so it shall be part
one you Hank as I was watching your
hilarious video yesterday and indeed as
I've watched your previous 130 videos I
always feel surprised I hope you won't
be insulted by this Hank but I'm
surprised that you're so smart and funny
and I think I know the reason I'm
surprised it's not because you just
became smart and funny it's because the
last time I knew you really well you
were 11 and Hank you can say a lot of
nice things about 11 year olds but their
wit does not tend to be nuanced for
instance all the jokes I told when I was
11 broadly speaking went like this set
up set up set up set up set up get you
ready for the punchline are you ready
for the punchline are you ready for the
punchline poop the punchline was always
poop Hank
whereas now that's only the punchline
like 30% of the time I think today for a
lot of people sibling hood is a
relationship that occurs primarily in
childhood and then when you're adults
you still talk but you mostly talk about
your parents or your other siblings or
familial matters of some kind and you
end up stuck with the same image of your
siblings that you had when they were
little
we're busy grown-ups who live across the
country from each other and there's not
always time to add in your pants to book
titles and see who can come up with
funnier ones by the way Hank my tripod
today is a stack of books and one of
those books is called Pompeii tales from
an eruption in your pants
I think it's an increasingly rare
pleasure to know your siblings as adults
and I have to tell you Hank I am so
grateful for this project primarily
because I now know you as an adult as a
smart funny clever person full of ideas
both brilliant naming our forum my pants
and diabolical making me wax my chin but
Hank I think it's safe to say that as
much as we've enjoyed this project with
each other we never would have finished
if people hadn't watched first because
it was hard and second because I love
not to finish stuff oh and speaking of
not finishing stuff Hank I went back
through the Brotherhood 2.0 archives to
find the first time that either of us
ever mentioned a viewer of brotherhood
2.0 and it was actually unlike January
4th the nerdfighter in question and
remember back then nerdfighters weren't
even calling themselves nerdfighters was
Peter who had just had a baby and I was
all like we're going to get
Peter a baby warming present but then we
didn't because I loved not finishing
things fortunately when fleet sent me an
extra copy of mummy how do I know if I'm
a nerdfighter I'm going to send it to
Peter as a three hundred sixty two day
late baby warming present and then I
will have actually completed the task
Hank that brings me to part two
nerdfighters Hank before I go I need to
make one thing clear nerdfighters are
not about you and me nerdfighters are
about a made of Awesome book made by a
woman in Australia going to a made of
awesome baby in the United States
nerdfighters are about raising money and
awareness for important causes
nerdfighters are about building a
supportive community of friends in my
pants nerdfighters are about stupid
beautiful projects and making each other
laugh and think with t-shirts and pocket
protectors and rants about the situation
in Pakistan which sucks right now in the
contemporary world where things fall
apart and the center cannot hold you
have to imagine a community where there
is no center Hank at the end of this
year I started to think that a lot of
life is about doing things that don't
suck with people who don't suck that's
why I enjoyed the happy dance project
and the project for awesome so much all
these people who don't suck came
together to do something that doesn't
suck and as I recall that's the point of
the scavenger hunt nerdfighters I'll see
you in my pants and Hank thanks for all
of this I'll see you on Monday
I know it could end real bad but I wish
it didn't have to end at all yeah I wish
it didn't have to end at all